once upon a time on the shores of the
baltic there was the capital of a small
duchy later to become a kingdom it was a
thriving and prosperous city equipped
with castles and fortifications home to
knights kings writers and philosophers
as well as the seat of an important
university its name was koenigsberg no
use looking it up on a map koenigsberg
no longer exists not under that name at
least you can find it nestled between
poland and lithuania under the name
kaliningrad the map will show it to you
as russian territory and that's not a
mistake kaliningrad is what is called an
exclave a portion of national territory
separated from the state to which it
belongs without territorial continuity
with it that is surrounded entirely by
other states like all exclaves
kaliningrad also has a special past
behind it and is precisely its
geographical and political anomaly that
makes it one of the most dangerous and
hot spots in the world today and we'll
find out why first however we must go
back to the time when the city was still
called koenigsberg founded by the
monastic order of the teutonic knights
in the 13th century and later becoming
the capital of the duchy of prussia from
which the process of national
unification began koenigsberg became
part of the german empire and was known
by that name until 1946. koenigsberg
then at least from the birth of the
kingdom of prussia in 1701 was to all
intents and purposes german territory
despite polish and lithuanian minorities
following the treaty of versailles in
1919 east prussia and konigsberg itself
were separated from the rest of germany
by a strip of polish territory the
gdansk corridor and very close to
koenigsberg a new independent national
entity would arise lithuania it would be
hithler with the polish invasion who
would re-establish territorial
continuity with koenigsberg at least
until 1945. during the final stages of
world war ii in fact the town like all
of east germany didn't escape the
offensive of the soviets who conquered
and occupied the town after months of
siege but unlike the other territories
of the now former east prussia conquered
by the red army which at the end of the
war would be divided between soviet
poland and lithuania the russians
retained direct control over koenigsberg
and the surrounding area they made it in
other words an oblast in effect russian
territory koenigsberg then ceased to
exist and draws from the ashes of
wartime kaliningrad renamed in honor of
a bolshevik revolutionary quite ironic
when we think that koenigsberg literally
means king's mountain the russians
separated the real restyling of the city
not only did they demolish most of the
historical monuments related to the
german pest by the way already heavily
damaged by bombing but they imposed the
russification of the city relocating the
german inhabitants left behind during
the war to east germany and replacing
them with russian citizens but what did
the russians do with this exclave first
with the division of europe into two
blocks and following the formation of
the war so packed kaliningrad was not an
exclave as it is today these socialist
republics of lithuania and latvia which
geographically separate kaliningrad from
russian territory were at the time an
integral part of the soviet union which
ensured territorial continuity between
kaliningrad and the motherland not to
mention the passage through belarus at
the time also incorporated among the
many socialist republics moreover soviet
leaders had clear ideas about the city's
fate from the very beginning indeed
kaliningrad and its entire oblast became
a military bastion by virtue of its
strategic location right in the middle
of the baltic it was for this reason
that stalin preferred to incorporate
kaliningrad into russian rather than
lithuanian territories its location was
vital to soviet military fortunes and so
it could only depend directly on the
kremlin's wishes indeed it was stalin's
own successor nikita khrushchev who
proposed to the lithuanian government
the total session of the oblast but it
was the lithuanians who this time
refused the offer since it would have
meant an exiting territory with a strong
russian-speaking minority remaining
under russian control from 1956
kaliningrad would host the soviet baltic
fleet previously stationed in the port
of leningrad present-day saint
petersburg indeed just outside the city
of kaliningrad lies the port of baltisk
which are like leningrad and the other
soviet ports on the baltic doesn't
freeze over in the colder months of the
year as a result the obelisk became one
of the most to militarize the regions of
the soviet union reaching 100 000
soldiers interdicted to foreign visitors
all of kaliningrad revolved around
moscow's wartime needs and throughout
the cold war the oblast was an offensive
projection of the soviet union to the
nato flank with those few ruined
monuments spared by the war and soviet
iconoclasm including the cathedral that
housed the remains of emmanuel kant one
of the most prestigious figures
originally from ancient koenigsberg the
city had nothing left of its former
glory it had become a veritable military
outpost and the nuclear warhead storage
site the conditions of the inhabitants
halfed from the pre-war period where in
poverty and degradation upon the fall of
the warsaw pact and the soviet union
kaliningrad's fortunes didn't improve
much certainly the distance from the
motherland was intensified indeed since
the three baltic republics declared
their independence territorial
continuity with the territories of the
soviet union was lacking for the
kaliningrad oblast neither poland nor
lithuania made any claims on a territory
that was now home to an exclusively
russian-speaking population despite the
fact that ancient koenigsberg between
the 16th and 17th centuries that is
before it passed into the duchy of
russia had been part of the kingdom of
poland the first end of the polish
lithuanian confederation later
kaliningrad remained russian territory
but given the city's precarious economic
conditions it couldn't survive without a
direct supply of basic goods from russia
in 1993 the post-soviet government in
moscow was forced to sign an agreement
with lithuania that guaranteed behind
strict controls and exorbitant tariffs
supplies by train to the exclave via the
infamous suvaki gap a 65 kilometer long
strip of land linking belarus a vassal
state of moscow even after the fall of
the soviet union to the kaliningrad
oblast crossing the border between
poland and lithuania on the geopolitical
and military implications of this strip
of land today we return later meanwhile
throughout the 1990s given the economic
precariousness of the newly formed
russian federation kaliningrad had to
fend for itself opening up to trade with
neighboring germany poland and lithuania
certainly more advantageous markets than
the shattered post-soviet russia but
economic crisis and geographic isolation
also meant a reduction in what had been
the exclave's crowning achievement its
military capacity whether due to
cutbacks and spending or lithuanian
controls on the transit of goods and
people the ground forces stationed in
kaliningrad fell from the 100 000
recorded in 1993 to 15 000 in 1998
russia on the other hand needed the bulk
of the troops in the south in chechnya
where throughout the second half of the
1990s and early 2000s it was forced to
deal with separatists and then in
kaliningrad being in the military was no
longer convenient many officers as well
as many war industries converted to more
civilian purposes the legendary fleet
had lost all its former greatness and as
felix gramov at the time head of the
russian navy would observe its power was
comparable to that of any other european
fleet certainly unable to be a threat to
nato kaliningrad was in short no longer
the tornado side and its fleet could
boast its own usefulness all in
defensive and controlled areas and in
peace time as in safeguarding sea trade
in a wartime scenario according to
western experts the exclave's isolation
and small number of its armaments made
kaliningrad a weak pawn on the other
side of the coin however this weakening
facilitated relations with the nato
itself which in turn reduced its
military projection in the baltic what
is more the russian federation's new
international role and its partnership
with nato involved the moscow and
kaliningrad itself in precisely those
joint exercises baltops once designed to
defend the baltic straits from possible
soviet aggressions not everyone looked
to kaliningrad with confidence and
serenity poland and lithuania which had
only been free from the grip of soviet
troops for a few years were very
suspicious of the russian giant
kaliningrad certainly posed no threat to
nato agreed but to the still immature
defenses of poland and lithuania i did
after unsuccessfully calling for the
total demilitarization of the russian
exclave poland and lithuania as well as
the other baltic republics decided to
shake off all these anxieties by
applying for admission into nato and the
european union poland was accepted into
nato in 1999 among others along with the
czech republic and hungary thus
beginning the much feared eastern
enlargement of the atlantic alliance it
was mainly the russian military that was
suspicious of these nato initiatives
because they feared that it would all
result in the installation of nuclear
warheads and the deployment of troops in
territories ever closer to russian
borders and if lithuania had also
decided to follow in polish footsteps
toward nato kaliningrad would have found
itself even more isolated because it was
enclosed between two nato countries for
the officials there was no other
solution it was necessary to return to
filling kaliningrad with weapons and men
as in the old days in the kremlin they
acted for the moment more on the
diplomatic and political side the
counter in fact couldn't join nato if
for example it had outstanding and
unresolved territorial disputes taking
advantage of this close russian
president boris yeltsin both time by
signing agreements with the three baltic
republics on board their regulation but
these were not ratified by the duma thus
leaving the dispute open one of these
agreements in 1997 concerned precisely
the borders between the kaliningrad
oblast and lithuania in this climate of
renewed distrust the nato military
intervention in kosovo distanced russia
even further from the west causing it to
discover a valuable ally neighboring
belarus it's no coincidence that a
military exercise zapat 99 which
simulated the nato nuclear attack on
kaliningrad would be carried out
precisely with minsk the exclave
returned to its peculiar strategic
importance especially under the new
russian president vladimir putin indeed
greater support for the navy was
promised as well as military
reinforcement of the region the very man
and then commander of the baltic fleet
admiral vladimir jagarov would be
elected in 2000 demonstrating that the
people of kaliningrad themselves still
had the military apparatus in high
regard and wanted increased defense
spending in the baltic meanwhile nato
activities continued and russian
officials feared at any moment that
lithuania might block the transit of
goods to kalinigram lithuania which
along with estonia and latvia will join
nato in 2004. although these signals
portended the return to the soviet past
there were also series of
counter-measures that at least for the
time being called the waters first the
establishment of the russian nato
council then the 2002 agreement between
moscow and washington on nuclear arms
reduction it was then putin himself who
avoided blowing on the fire of mistrust
when he welcomed with some benevolence
the entry of the three baltic republics
into nato an enlargement that he said
was unnecessary but after all didn't
directly threaten russia the early 2000s
resulted in an alternation of distrust
and closeness between nato and russia
but kaliningrad still remained not to be
solved and lithuania's entry not only
into nato but also into the european
union in 2004 complicated matters and
not only militarily vilnius succession
to the schengen convention made the
issue of passage to kaliningrad from
russia even thornier a situation that
putin denounced as detrimental to
national sovereignty and the human
rights of russian citizens then there
was fear among many officials about the
european union's real intentions namely
to make kaliningrad the new west berlin
in fact no final agreement was ever
reached between the european union and
russia on the issue of transit visas
through lithuania and all negotiations
stalled in recent years yes because in
the meantime the russian economy had
grown at a stable pace and as a result
military spending had also been revived
the kremlin's foreign policy thus became
more aggressive beginning in 2008 with
the invasion of georgia dating from the
year before among other things was the
bush administration's decision to deploy
an anti-iranian missile shield in poland
and the czech republic a move that was
obviously not appreciated by the kremlin
and it was the 2005 that saw the first
color the revolutions in the former
socialist republics it was ukraine with
the orange revolution that set the
course relations between russia and the
nato became as frosty as ever and
kaliningrad was still at risk of
isolation with lithuania which in
response threatened to block russian
military transit to kaliningrad until
the end of the conflict it was russia
itself however that had announced the
withdrawal of 800 tanks from kaliningrad
as a sign of its non-aggressive
intentions by now however the die had
been cast and the new phase of total
dependence on the motherland opened for
kaliningrad given the new isolation into
which it had fallen the united states
and poland signed an agreement to deploy
missile warheads on polish soil and the
russian response was not long incoming
missiles also incan immigrant this was
what was decided by the russian
president at the time dimitri medvedev
partly in reaction to the presence of
american warships deployed in the black
sea according to medvedev the situation
in georgia had been used as a pretext to
implement anti-russian military measures
in europe if the situation in 2008 was
tense it could only get worse in 2014.
following the unilateral annexation of
crimea russia rediscovered in
kaliningrad a key strategic and
organizational base as early as 2013
large scale exercises were held in the
exclave involving 9 000 troops 55 novel
vessels and the entire air force
according to the economist and in 2016
the much feared scandal missiles were
finally deployed in short more of a visa
problem for at least eight years then
the kaliningrad that has returned to its
old war tradition has been in danger of
becoming the epicenter of a conflict
that was as unplanned as it was
accidental how much was risked for
example in april 2015 when in disguise
over the baltic a russian jet skimmed
the us's pipeline narrowly avoiding a
collision that could have cost dearly
this episode is certainly not an
isolated one and let's not forget that
kaliningrad oblast in addition to the
baltic fleet is home to the chernakovsk
and danskoi airbases from which russian
jets can attack the baltic states in a
very short time leaving them in
sufficient time for a counter-offensive
in a sense with the baltic increasingly
an atlantic lake and with the imminent
entries of sweden and finland into nato
kaliningrad assumes even more vital
importance for russia today than it did
at the height of the cold war the
military axis of kaliningrad and the
novel bases of saint petersburg and
kronstadt island in the gulf of finland
represents the russian screen against
nato's baltic projections a screen
however interrupted by lithuania latvia
and estonia themselves whose two islands
of yuma and sarema go to former together
with the danish island of bornholm the
swedish islands of ireland gutska
sandhun and especially gutland the nerve
center of nato operations a stranglehold
on russian ports and kaliningrad itself
the war however finally came in ukraine
for the time being but the news of these
days opens up the possibility of an
extended conflict right toward the
baltic indeed the lithuania is back to
blocking the transit of russian goods
through the tsubaki gap in compliance
with sanctions set by the european union
in fact they are keen to point out from
williams the blockade would cover only
sanctioned goods so not foodstuffs for
example all that would be left to supply
kaliningrad would be the sea route which
is expensive and logistically complex
for moscow this act is a clear violation
of its sovereignty while waiting for a
decision from brussels russia and the
person of dmitry medvedev now vice
president of the russian security
council has threatened economic and
energy retaliation not excluding of
course worst case scenarios and not only
with regard to billions maybe the
governor of kaliningrad himself anton
alikanov has let it be known that he has
submitted draft proposals to the kremlin
in response to the blockade proposals
that present unspecified measures but
critical of lithuania although it can't
be ruled out according to many that
russian economic and energy reactions
may also involve other countries maybe
just the other two baltic republics
indeed some analysts point out the
concomitants with the temporary blocking
of the two sections of the north stream
pipeline for maintenance and the fear is
that this halt to gas supplies could
last longer at least until a
satisfactory agreement on the fate of
kaliningrad is reached but the zubalki
gap today for the russians has an
importance that goes beyond the economic
level alone under the protest of
intervening to protect supplies to its
exclave russia could also intervene
militarily to secure control of the gap
via belarus of course but doing so would
create a rupture on the baltic front of
nato cutting off lithuania and then
latvia and estonia from poland that is
from the rest of nato actions that could
in turn result in the first step to
invade the very three baltic republics
even though clearly at that point nato
article 5 would be triggered
automatically in this sense it's from
what will happen in the next few days in
the tree border between poland lithuania
and kaliningrad that it will be possible
to tell whether this conflict will
spread with incalculable outcomes it
would also remain to be understood
exactly what lies behind vilnius
decision is it a simple compliance with
european directives or a deliberate
provocative strategy to what end them
and directed by whom beyond everything
what is emerging in the kaliningrad
issue these days is a kind of nato split
that sees the baltic and scandinavian
countries as the main reference of the
united states in european affairs partly
because they are the most exposed to
russian retaliation for its part
kaliningrad seems ready to take the
field in the end war in ancient
koenigsberg may have arrived well we are
done for today as well thank you all for
your attention and see you in the next
video ciao